[Music]
nashville
tennessee where all the city's a stage
they call it music city but for one
night only
it's not about singing country it's
about running it
[Music]
[Applause]
in round two of televised debates the
men on stage
will be the men in suits i want to see
something
that is not like the last debate more
civil you know
talking about more of the issues that
affect americans i guess biden show
trump what a real president should look
like
i want to see them actually get to talk
and not get interrupted and i want to
see them actually give trump a chance
to explain himself and rather not cut
him off
inside nashville's belmont university
they've taken measures to prevent the
interruptions of the first debate
microphones can be muted
candidate preparations have been low key
versus high profile
the democrat challenger has been
preparing at his delaware home
in private
[Applause]
donald trump has been rehearsing attack
lines
in public and as far as i'm concerned
the biden family is a criminal
enterprise it really is
look at what's going on donald trump has
warned
unverified claims surrounding the
business dealings of joe biden's son
hunter if you have lots of unfavorables
the other way to try to make an election
close is to bring down the other side
and so i think president trump
is going to try to rally his base and
talk about um the vice president's son
in this situation
and try to make it like every you know
politics is just a nasty
unfortunate event an event an
unfortunate sport
and trying to make it unpleasant to
americans and try to depress her now
whatever the impact of presidential
debates they do bring
intensity and unpredictability in an
otherwise controlled campaign
for joe biden in particular many have
long viewed these tv debates
first and foremost as a fitness test
would they expose a 77 year old man
as unfit for office trump
needs to upset the rhythm of this
campaign
biden needs not to lose it